[Music]
this morning on the dish simon rogan and
lon cloon
the two-star michelin restaurant
features one of the world's most
elaborate tasting menus inside a 13th
century building
since opening 20 years ago lancloom has
been named best restaurant in england
six times it is not easy to reach five
hours north of london harder to get a
reservation
but for those who make it they get way
more than a meal it is art history and
food
colliding in one extraordinary place
visiting the small village of cartomel
in northern england is a bit like taking
a step back in time
nero winding roads wrap around stone
buildings erected in the middle ages
inside one of those buildings is a
restaurant called lancloom or
the anvil people say to us when they
come here who did your interior design
well you know it did itself you know
it's uh it's not changed it's since the
13th century atlan klum carefully
choreographed team of cooks start early
in the morning executing a vision of a
man whose extravagant tasting dinners
have become a modern day masterpiece
simon rogan the chef never afraid to
bite off as much as you can possibly
chew ten years ago this was nothing 2011
yeah we
entered an empty field and thought this
would be a perfect location
for our new facility unsatisfied with
the produce he was receiving at lawn
plume we'll take some of these tomorrow
for the cabbage dish that we're going to
do rogan cut out the middle man and
built his own farm blimey
sharp sharp powerful
even the thing like uh like a radish
having the perfect radish which is so
easy to grow was reaching us in such
poor quality so that's how we started
farming growing radishes and that's what
this allows you i mean it's beautiful i
mean look at
it yeah well things obviously things
progressed and yeah then it moved on to
roots carrots turnips all sorts of kales
lettuces i mean you know there's nothing
we we don't grow now
rogan says that how something is grown
is more important than how it's cooked
you just pick off and that's a real
real hit of a nice flavor
packs a punch
yeah it does does that
that said the cooking that takes place
inside line plume is about as elevated
as it gets the tasting menus consist of
anywhere between 15 to 18 courses and
we've got some little spinach leaves
which are lovely and juicy it's called
new zealand spinach what was the idea
behind making the menu just a tasting
menu
i always like tastes the way that i like
to eat myself as many little tastes and
textures
as possible within a mil
i like to see a lot of different
variation and interesting techniques so
just a bit of a performance and
you know really showcasing what we've
got around us and and
what techniques
we have really the technical detail and
precision put into every plating is
remarkable to watch
eat and given the elaborate displays
describe
but here's a small sampling dish number
one okay so this yeah we like to start
off the meal with a series of little
snacks just to get the the taste buds
going so
this one is a little tart made from
dehydrated gooseberry juice the
gooseberry juice tartlet is filled with
lobster tail dressed in an emulsion of
the lobster head
rose hip puree and chopped cherry bell
radishes
there's layers
that's the things are making
something look so simple have that x
factor
delicious
next up was a fritter of smoked eel and
confit pork in an onion tapioca crumb
with fermented sweet corn dusted with
lavage powder
cassandra cucumbers compressed in
calament raw scallops and pickled
elderflower fish and shellfish is the
only thing that we can't actually
create ourselves if we could we would
but we leave it to the experts that side
of things zucchini roasted in yeast and
fennel pollen pickled quail eggs and
herbs
grilled cabbage cooked in buttermilk and
served with hen of the woods mushrooms
horseradish and welsh truffles
turbo with kale leaves and smoked roe
bay sea vegetables and a sauce made from
mussel stock sour cream and gooseberries
and finally the anvil rogan's signature
dessert
caramel mousse flavored with homemade
miso
sprayed with bronze and sitting in a bed
of caramelized apples
oh my goodness
wow
layers again
oh boy delicious
since opening lancloom in 2001 simon
rogan has expanded there's now a chef's
tasting room next door plus his one
michelin star casual location down the
street he's also opened a spot in london
and two in hong kong
he has his eyes on new york city next
if history is any guide america is in
for something exquisite i mean it's been
a been an amazing journey
and i've got an amazing team around me
that enabled me to look at new projects
and
see the world a bit more which is what
being a chef's all about is getting out
there experience in the world and
spirits in different cultures
cheers
cheers
i think the most elaborate and
technically precise meal i've ever seen
yes it looks prepared the amount of work
that goes into each one of those small
little tastes right
um we don't have any of these of course
18 dishes here because it was weeks ago
so you're taking us overseas and it's
across the pond so i'm going to take
both of you
to england and we'll go to london
together or thomas's promises jeff
you've been making a lot of those what
do you mean
when he opens in new york there it is